look me neither and I had you though we
had two people trip over it yesterday I
feel like we're trying to mess with
people I made him hold on to me coming
out and then as soon as he let go I
tripped walking here so it's been a
while since I've worn heels so I blame
Max he let go yeah oh let me tell you a
lot of people blame me for a lot of
things
please do it for me Max well by the way
I think that Max and I were talking
about you the last time we were here yes
I remember I saw it oh you did I did and
um I'm really disappointed in you both
that you don't know what milkweed is
when she was on here
um it reminds me she was saying that she
gave away like some kind of butter to
feed butterfly she gave something away
to like all her neighbors did she give
it to you too it was like she flowers
like milkweed or something she's
there's some sort of plant or animal
because milkweed she gave it to her she
didn't give you any oh she didn't make
the cut
apparently not uh I do feel bad about
that that I didn't give him anything I
know I feel like we're disappointed in
you but neither one of us got milk I did
bring you a gift I did drop half the
ball because I did go to a nursery and
get milkweed seeds and they are not in
my purse but I did bring you these
bumper stickers to show you what
milkweed looks like it does have a
flower Kelly oh I know it is since my
milkweed brings all the monarchs to the
yard
and if I don't see it on your cars I
really want to put this on my Bronco oh
my God in your Bronco it'll be so cool
wait do you Garden I can't see you I'm
going to move it too yeah wait do you
Garden do you do anything this is so
much better I know the view is
spectacular I've heard yeah yes man do
you do anything outdoors no no look at
the triathlon yeah I'm I go out it's
outdoors I go outside wait what the one
in the world that was a lie your answer
is a lie okay yeah you're outdoorsy
yeah that's what that means sure I
that's super outdoorsy we've been
outdoors in an extended amount of period
to conquer that and you almost forgot it
was a couple hours you almost drowned
yes
um I did almost drown there was what
don't you have to sign something I have
to sign things with production
I just I ignore it I tell them that I'm
just gonna go for a walk
um I told this one
there was a woman who I did the
triathlon with uh the year before and
she was like I'm really worried about
the swim in and I said I go don't worry
about this and she goes yeah I'm worried
about a wave coming over hitting me in
the head and I go all right that's never
gonna happen
I start swimming in which is like you
know it's towards the end and you're not
even going it feels like I'm not really
moving anywhere and the next thing you
know just as I had that thought a wave
came over and smashed me so hard in the
head goggles go off my body is going
everywhere and I think to myself
huh
this is how I die
I have had this moment with a big huge
the waves kept coming in in Hawaii and I
was like they're not the universe is not
taking this day for me I had like one
day I got really calm did you get I got
so calm because I remembered that
somebody said a long time ago that
you're supposed to get really calm and
just let your body naturally float up
and quit fighting it yeah I just got I
got real calm I don't know if it was
that or if I was just like all right
it's been great courses don't do that
yeah so wait wait you so max you're
gonna judge um an upcoming drag show
right is that true yes thank you have
you always want to do this I want to see
I've wanted to well specifically this
one it's called best in drag La okay
Sports uh the alliance for housing and
healing which uh supports homeless
people in Los Angeles uh finds housing
for them specifically those who are uh
who have HIV and AIDS wow they do this
every year it's this massive drag show
I've asked every year if I could be uh
one of the judges to no avail
and I finally got in
are you so excited wait what are so wait
what do you love most about a drag show
what's what's going to win you over well
I appreciate the commitment
I mean they are the point of drowning
but he really does the commitment to the
outfits the names the back story
everything that's it's just it's it's
spectacular it's all I want they're more
committed than I am as a father
that is not true we're taking that out
we're taking that out that is not true
we'll leave it in only because it's not
true I can't even believe this I didn't
open with this but now you're a mama I
am that's the last time I saw you that's
exciting best thing ever that is
that's her hand oh my gosh that smokes
Emma we're in love it's amazing and
wonderful I love that for you it is a
special time I like skin on skin when
they're like so little all in the smell
she just started giggling and laughing
and I can make her laugh which as a
comedian it's like the most exciting
thing but it I try really hard and
sometimes she's like you're not
committed enough because she's not
trying to yeah you're trying way too
hard honey but then if I just don't try
and she laughs it's the best feeling
wait do you did you ever give her any
advice with parenting I mean since
you're a stellar dad and all
I I just I try to show up to work uh
looking rested
um and I continue to tell her that it's
the best it is though and he's a very
good dad and I texted him he texted me a
couple days after she was born and was
like how's it going how is she and I was
like it's amazing I want a hundred kids
and he just was like no you don't and
then like three months in I'm like yeah
yeah I'm good I can't start to get
outnumbered yeah oh see I don't know how
that because well I'm a single parent
now so I'm outnumbered at night and I'm
like very different like yeah yeah I
can't imagine that you have to go
Warrior you have to find your inner
warrior yeah I can stronger yeah there
we go I did it I did it so no one else
could um so max you're going out with
another kids book in October that's
awesome what's this one what's this one
about yes uh this is a follow-up to the
first one I don't want to read this book
this one is called this book is not a
present uh it was ins yes it was
inspired by my son
uh I tried to play a trick on him
because I wanted to see if it worked and
I gave him a present and I said I got
you a present and he went oh my God and
he goes what is it a Lego video game and
I go I don't even know what that is I
think you just like Legos and video
games and you're putting them together
yeah
and I go no so excited I go
I go it's a book
and he went
[Music]
and then he physically assaulted me
and it was terrible and I go this is
okay the book's gonna work so it's
basically all the reasons why it's
terrible getting a book as a present
unwrapping it opening it up and
realizing it's not Legos or a video game
and it's words and pages and this feels
like work yeah I'm laughing because your
books are so relatable for parents and
for kids because when I read the title I
was like oh this past Christmas I
literally get I always give them books
they love books so I got them along with
a plethora of other gifts but they open
and it was just like the sadness that
ensued I was like oh yeah they just
weren't excited about it anymore and I'm
like that's fine it's like
yes I like I'm gonna use the bumper
sticker
the neighborhood is now in season five
so this is huge it's awesome to have a
show that has longevity like this so
what is it what's going on how's it
feeling
it feels awesome yeah we have the best
group of people ever like the chemistry
is like genuinely I know people say it
about their shows and sometimes they're
lying yeah we're not lying like it's
truly I wouldn't be here right now with
Beth right at work I drove her over we
carved I love that though I think that
makes a difference you can tell like
it's transparent for the viewers yeah I
honestly think especially on a multicams
sitcom you can tell when the cast is
having fun and when they like each other
and it's nice to be on a show where
you're just like oh I'll do this for as
long as CBS will have us yeah oh and
that's okay we all want to do it forever
yeah no that's amazing it's not every
job is like that for all of us in the
industry whatever your well any industry
really and that's amazing when you find
people that you click with and it works
and people love it so congratulations so
Beth
um I don't know we'll know wait Beth
talked about dancing on set before that
you all both dance and we I heard about
your dancing yeah yeah I heard about
your dancing wasn't it with Prince the
last time we were like yes that's right
oh I remember yeah oh I don't I dance
with Prince
you're only cool a little bit Yeah so I
wanted to show you should be there but
still yeah I wanted to show this Tick
Tock that you made oh boy so here we go
so here's my
we've come so far from Prince like is
so wait wait who who got you to do that
was it your idea my daughter is your
daughter my daughter and her friends
were over they've been begging me to
join Tick Tock you're making a tick tock
is a whole process but anyway so they
set up the camera and the three of them
are standing behind it going this is how
you do the moves and
let me tell you that there were multiple
takes and I was being again abused
um verbally this time I was like guys
this isn't easy for me
um but we finally I think we finally
came out to it it it it it worked out
you worked out we got to a place where
everybody was happy okay I just feel
like who do you think the best dancer is
on set if we're gonna have to be honest
about this guy who did you say they feel
like it's me
I think it goes Cedric I actually have
never seen Tashina dance
everything is me Tashina would say it's
me 100 are wait are you putting a person
you haven't seen dance above her I know
I'm putting her at the bottom I've never
seen it I'm gonna put Tashina at the
bottom okay she's got the best voice by
far by far but so I'm gonna go Cedric
and then I'm gonna say me and then I'm
gonna say that
you saw that Tick Tock we did that's
what he thinks that dancing is and
Prince I saw I saw the prince thing too
so wait I I have a band so I was just
thinking that maybe we could have a
dance off here I was just thinking
like y'all haven't seen
okay
okay
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]